في تطورات الملف الايراني قال تقرير
استخباراتي امريكي الى ايران تواصل تجاوز
القيود التي فرضها الاتفاق نووي على البحث
والتطوير في اجهزه الطرد المركزي المتقدمه
وتواصل زياده مخزونها من اليورانيوم
والمخصبه وذكر التقرير ان ايران تستمر في
عمليات تخصيب اليورانيوم بمنشاه التي كانت
محظوره بموجب الاتفاق النووي وحزب التقرير
للاستخباراتيه الامريكي فان من المحتمل ان
يفكر المسؤولون الايرانيون في تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 90% اذا لم تخفف
العقوبات عليهم كما يشير الى انه منذ
اغتيال العالم النووي محسن فخري زاد سرعت
ايران توسيع برنامجها النووي وقامت بانشطه
بحث وتطوير من شانها ان تقربها من انتاج
المواد الانشطاريه اللازمه لانتاج سلاح
النووي
وكانت البعثه الامريكيه لدى المنظمات
الدوليه في فيينا قد اتهم الطهران بمواصله
توسيع برنامجها النووي الى ما هو ابعد من
حدود الاتفاق النووي واشارت الى ان
استمرار طهران في انتاج اليورانيوم المخصب
بنسبه تصل الى
60% ليس له اي اغراض سلبيه موثوقه ويجب
عليها ان تكف عن هذا النشاط المقلق للغايه
وفق تعبيرها
هذا وقالت مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
الامريكيه افريل هاينز في جلسه استماع
للجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس الشيوخ قالت ان
ايران ما زالت تمثل تهديدا لاسرائيل سواء
بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر وذلك من خلال حزب
الله ووكلاء اخرين على حد تعبيرها
وتنضم الينا من الكونجرس مراسله الجزيره
بيسان ابو كويك نيسان اهلا بك اذا في جلسه
الاستماع بالكونجرس الملف النووي الايراني
حاضر في المناقشات
بالفعل خديجه طبعا هذه الجلسه تتناول هذا
التقييم والتقرير الذي يتناول التهديدات
على الصعيد الدولي روسيا والصين وايران هي
ابرز العناوين بالنسبه لايران ما سمعناه
من مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه عبر الهينز
بان ايران ما زالت تمثل تهديدا مباشرا
وغير مباشر عبر وكلائها على
الامريكيين ايضا تمثل تهديدا على اسرائيل
بشكل مباشر ان كان من خلال
الصواريخ والمسيرات او بشكل غير مباشر من
خلال وكلائها كحزب الله بالنسبه لبرنامجها
النووي اشارت افريلز ويشير التقرير ايضا
بان ايران سارعت في تطوير برنامجها النووي
التحليلات الاستخباراتيه تشير الى ان هذا
حصل مع انسحاب الاداره الامريكيه الس من
الاتفاق النووي وان ايران الان لم تعد
ملتزمه لذلك الاتفاق وانها بلغت حدا من
التطور بحيث طورت المواد الانشطاريه
اللازمه لتطوير سلاح نووي في حال تم اتخاذ
قرار بتطوير هذا السلاح وهيمز اشارت
تحديدا الى انه حتى اللحظه التقييمات
الاستخباراتيه تشير الى انه لم يتخذ ذلك
القرار وكان هناك اشاره ايضا الى ان
اغتيال العالم النووي سرع من عمليه
التطوير ايران
لبرنامجها النووي باجراء البحوث وباجراء
ايضا
خطوات
لتطويره ايضا هذه في هذه الجلسه يعني كان
هناك قلق ربما واضح خصوصا من مشارعين
جمهوريين ازاءه هذه النقطه وهذا التسارع
او في البرنامج النووي
الايراني
وايضا كان هناك كلام عن
تطوير حتى شبكات داخل ربما الولايات
المتحده من قبل ايران فيما يتعلق
بالتهديدات السبرانيه كان هناك اشارات الى
الصين مثلا ولكن فيما يتعلق بايران تحديدا
اشاره هند الى ان ايران ربما لن تتوانى
وهي اكثر عدائيه في شان هجمات سيبرانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك بيسان ابو كويك كنتي معنا
من مقر الكونجرس